it's great to welcome to the program
today Wendy brown who's a professor of
political science at UC Berkeley and
also author most recently of in the
ruins of neoliberalism the rise of
anti-democratic politics in the West
Wendy's so great to have you on thanks
for having me so first just so we're all
hopefully working with the sort of same
definition of neoliberalism I think it's
a much understood and and much
understood and debated term in the
context that you write about it how what
are the important tenets that define
neoliberalism so just to be clear to
start with because I do think it's
confusing to many Americans yes bye-bye
neoliberalism the original neoliberals
Milton Friedman Friedrich Hayek and
others were referring to a modification
of economic liberalism and I only want
to make that clear because still so many
Americans imagine that it has something
to do with our notion of political
liberalism where it has to do with more
equality more social spending more state
and so forth and it's just the opposite
neoliberalism as the founding fathers of
it thought about neoliberalism meant
taking the basic principles of economic
liberalism that is unregulated markets
maximized competition and and and
modifying those and the modifications
that they imagined and that it actually
have come to be involved two things one
understanding that markets are not
necessarily natural even if they're good
so they need a lot of state support they
don't need state intervention but they
need state support they need the state
oriented to the issue of making markets
work and making markets thrive and the
other thing that they did to modify the
original adam smith's notions of
liberalism
had to do with bringing traditional
morality into the picture understanding
that not just markets but also morals
were what ought to be organizing social
life
cultural life familial life and so forth
and the reason I emphasize that is that
so many of us talk about neoliberalism
just as instead of economic policies
what we need to understand that it also
has this other dimension a dimension
that of course has really come to the
fore as we think about contemporary
political life yeah I mean what was the
trajectory of that in history because
it's not necessarily obvious that what
starts as a set of economic principles
would eventually come to encompass a
particular view about so-called you know
traditional family values or that it
would dictate certain foreign policy as
often is a part of discussions about
neoliberal versus other points of view
what was the trajectory through which
those elements became wrapped up in this
sort of bigger understanding of
neoliberalism in the last 20 or 30 years
the fundamental attack that
neoliberalism mates on the social State
on Keynesianism on practices of social
justice that have to do with legislation
of the good the fundamental attack that
neoliberalism makes is this it says
better that what we have is just
organically developed morality and
markets organizing society and that
means less democratic legislation in
fact the neoliberals were extremely
suspicious of and really tried to modify
and and and diminish the extent to which
legislators in electoral democracies
should do anything other than just set
general laws for people so they really
wanted legislators out of the social
justice business out of the market
regulation business and certainly out of
the taxation business so those two
things come together morality and market
in the attack that neoliberals make on
democratic ways of deciding how we
should live together
how much equality we should have how
much inclusion we should have how we
ought to deal with things like gender
power racial power
power and so forth all of those the
neoliberals wanted left alone so that
traditional morality and markets could
govern our lives and they believed that
that would maximize freedom and maximize
the good maximize a good society yeah
one of the things that that is
interesting to me as I understand that
and I'm curious if you believe that the
same kind of inherent contradiction
exists is that in a lot of the ideology
that's espoused about neoliberalism and
these free market less regulation
letting increasing freedom the language
is very much about getting out of the
way to allow more Liberty to exist but
in practice that getting out of the way
to the extent that it exists and of
course it's much more complicated than
that
can actually allow a lot of different
types of authoritarianism today hold in
different ways is is that a
contradiction that you agree exists
there well for them it's not a
contradiction for us it seems that way
how come what starts as a project or a
program of freedom ends up in the kind
of authoritarianism that we see in the
bolsa Naro regime many of us argue is
taking shape under Trump and air21 and
so forth yes but for for inside a
neoliberal frame the thinking goes like
this it's okay to have strong states as
long as you maximize individual liberty
strong states are the way that you will
ensure that individuals can engage in
market conduct and have the the moral
life the social life that they choose
but what a state must not do is
intervene in individual freedoms so to
put this in in fairly simple language
what Neal liberals thought was all right
was a form of what we might call
authoritarian liberalism that is a
strong state making decisions
indifferent to what we call the checks
and balance
and three branches of government and all
of that a strong state making decisions
but leaving a lone private life leaving
a lone individual life and that's what
really distinguishes the authoritarian
liberalism taking shape today and that
many on the right support from classic
fascism well yeah and well the other
thing that's interesting to me there is
there's a lot of overlap between that
ideology and sort of what we might
consider traditional right
libertarianism not social libertarianism
but right libertarianism except when it
comes to foreign policy neoliberalism
has been much more interventionist than
the right libertarians at least claimed
that they would be they I don't know
that they've ever really gotten a shot
to show us how non interventionist they
would be but that in practice seems to
be a very big distinguishing factor
despite the talk of freedom and the
individual liberty being the most
important form of it
neoliberalism has been extraordinarily
interventionist in terms of foreign
policy correct now here again just if
I'm to try to explain what neo liberals
think they're doing what is what they
imagine they're trying to do is create a
world of global free trade now what's
happening right now is another story
with the trade wars and so forth but
with the classic neoliberal foreign
policy advocates thought they were doing
for example in Iraq regime change in
Iraq and then neoliberal eyes the
society make it into part of the global
order of among other things debt
financing and free trade and so forth so
you're absolutely right that they
understand a highly interventionist
foreign policy as part of what is
bringing about the neoliberal order but
there's one other area that I would
emphasize where new the the kind of
markets and morals program of the
neoliberals seems to really intervene in
individual liberty and that's of course
reproductive freedom and LGBT rights and
again the official thinking here is well
that has
with the moral order these things go
against traditional morality which is
tried and true and belongs part and
parcel with a free-market society so
it's slippery there but there you really
do have a contradiction
lots of intervention and the freedom of
women and non normative sexualities
saying no you can't do that there is the
I guess I we could call it the hope
among many on the American Left that
socially democratic ideas that are
similar to those of the Scandinavian
economies northern Europe etc are
experiencing maybe a resurgence a
renaissance of sorts or maybe
approaching something new that maybe
we've not even seen before in the United
States and that the rise of those ideas
will necessarily push out some of the
neoliberal framework that has been the
status quo for a long time is it as
clear as if one goes up the other goes
down is it more complicated than that do
you even agree that that's actually a
trend that we're now seeing I do think
that there has been a fairly robust
challenge to neoliberal ideas really
since the 2008 finance capital meltdown
I mean that was the beginning of the end
of a broad endorsement of free markets
privatization minimal social state
depression of progressive taxation the
post 2008 rethink went beyond occupy
although occupy really embodied at that
you know and what we need to remember is
that however limited the actual
timeframe of Occupy Wall Street what it
did was begin to change the conversation
about inequality about access to public
education higher education about banks
being given free rein to do whatever
they wanted about bailing out the banks
but not the foreclosed home owners and
so forth so with that conversation now
changed
you get the rise of Bernie Sanders and
in turn a OC and Elizabeth Warren and so
forth such that I I would actually agree
that what you have is a fairly robust
challenge now to neoliberal economic
ideas but I would say a little bit less
savvy on the part of the left about the
extent to which neoliberalism is also
bound up with this idea that the state
should stay out of the moral realm by
which is met the social justice realm
again the left has certainly been robust
on the subject of arguing for gender
rights LGBT rights black civil rights is
endorsing all kinds of social movement
but I but I do think it's the part of
the story that's more complicated is
taking apart that broad belief that
neoliberalism set into our bones of
society that it's best for the state to
be out of the business of social justice
redistribution social spending and all
the rest and to just let those things be
handled individually so to put up fine
to compress the point I do think that we
have a pretty major challenge now to
neoliberal economic thinking but maybe
not a full grasp of the way that what I
call neoliberal reason has has really
come to organize a lot of our
understanding of society and what's
appropriate for democratic legislation
yeah I've also found the the challenge
to be less robust when it comes to
foreign policy I mean you do hear hey we
shouldn't be getting it we're not the
world's policemen we should be getting
out of here there the other place but
it's been a less sort of nuanced than
well thought out challenge I don't know
if you would agree I totally agree and I
think that in many ways in the United
States
Trump has really confused the left in
its own rethinking its own thinking
about foreign policy because he stands
now for what the anti-imperial left used
to stand for which is get out of the
endless wars don't be the world's Polly
of course he's trying to do all kinds of
things at the level of trade and still
engaged in massive what we could call
neo-colonial condemnation of all kinds
of nations and practices but the
withdrawal that has typically been the
stance of many on the left has really I
think not been fully come to terms with
by the left to think about okay where
where does the Left stand on the
question of joining together with others
in the world not just to solve climate
change not just to get institutions of
political economy right but also to
right wrongs where are we the human
rights discourse where are we with
humanitarian intervention and the left
has gone super quiet on those subjects
absolutely fascinating we've been
talking with Wendy brown who's professor
of political science at UC Berkeley most
recently author of in the ruins of
neoliberalism the rise of
anti-democratic politics in the West
Wendy's such a pleasure having you on I
appreciate your time David it was good
to talk to you thank you